did you know that in Jiu Jitsu Kai is in
Megami has tried to kill himself at
least five separate times the first
occasion was in episode 1 when he tried
to summon his most uncontrollable and
dangerous shikigami and then he tried to
do the same thing again during his fight
with sukuna at the prison the third time
came during the Goodwill event when
harami broke in and started fighting
them and the fourth time was when he had
to fight one of the finger bearers by
himself finally the fifth time came
during the shibuyak when he was injured
and was being attacked by haruta and the
interesting thing about this one is that
on the fifth occasion he did actually
succeed in this particular Arc he
actually summoned maharaga which is the
shikigami that I was talking about and
it instantly kills Megami but because of
the way the ritual works his death
wasn't finalized until the ritual was
done this gave sukune the time he needed
to swoop in and heal Megami with reverse
curse technique but if haruta had been
killed before sukuna showed up then both
he and megmi would have died because the
ritual would have been over